[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another Friday alright so welcome back
to Friday's repeat if I it's basically
my weekly check-in with ebro's my
subscribers and know what they're here
to see what's up everything is going on
pretty well I think it leaves pretty
things have been going insanely awesome
lately last week I said thank you for
half a million subs and this week we
have 600,000 subs which is basically
we've been the fastest growing channel
on YouTube during this two-week which is
like how the heck did that happen I'll
never know but I'm I'm overwhelmed by
all the support of you bros so thank you
thank you very much thank you so much I
mean anyway um I basically if you
remember the last episode I had like a
music competition or whatever it's just
a small thing but oh wait it's a huge
thing everything would be ma I don't
know we're talking about the submissions
were amazing like I I just had the
biggest smile on my face when I went
through all that it was just an awesome
thing to go and to see I you know there
were so many births making really
talented and funny and creative songs so
instead of me choosing a winner I'm
gonna let you bros decide who's gonna
win so I made a playlist of my top 10
favorites which you can find in the
description so go there check all of
them out because they're all worth your
time I think at least and don't be too
quick to judge because some of them are
be really funny and awesome and every
okay whatever I just a little taste of
some awesomeness his russian road did a
beatbox
fridays with pewdiepie and his pants
were unzipped i don't know what's up
with that there was also this him a
message
bro that i don't know it was just
awesome a lot of covers and
electrum mix and staffing i don't know
it was really cool submissions and I
really hope you Brits check them all out
I don't know it was really amazing to
see all this submissions day I think
things like this is really what makes a
YouTube worthwhile and fun for me like
all the things in Hebrew so if it was
just me in front of the camera there's
no way I would have kept doing it I know
I say that a lot but if it's true and I
still read most almost all the comments
that I get and I really appreciate
everything from a comment to a song this
fan art and just anything you do Bros it
really means a lot and thank you for us
for the ice cream - that was really a
lot of fun
it was really crazy because I was
playing this I don't know you probably
saw and then I would play with this
custom story that I didn't think was
really scary or interesting and then all
the sudden like my amp would scare my
frickin life I don't know well well well
well well
everyone just take it no no no no no
Nate [ __ ] guidance all right then
whoa he's coming up
[Music]
a lot of you bros were like you see
crying is she crying I think I was
crying then I realized that there were
people live watching this I had to play
it off or something I don't know that
I'll definitely do more live streaming
so if you missed it don't worry there
will be more I always announce them here
alumni voice crack these days but yeah I
think that was pretty much it for this
Friday
don't forget to vote it's important that
we choose the winner because the winner
will be uploaded on my channel which is
pretty cool
stay awesome bros and stay awesome I
can't ask for more
anyway put your fish stuff brothers
alright don't don't deny the brofist I
know there's a lot of Bruce at breakfast
every week and I appreciate it and I
think it's pretty lame that you watch
this show and you don't even finish me
the broth it's like dude what's your
deal
I don't all right there we go I finally
see a breath of them alright here we go
three two one bro I'll brofist caramel
activate